[Music]
at first glance Google cloud platform is
huge there are so many tools services
and AP is that sometimes it can be
difficult to know how it all fits
together especially if you have existing
applications where what you use and what
GCP offers don't seem to match up
directly if you've been intrigued by the
prospect of migrating the GCP but
haven't known where to start
don't worry we are here to help let's
take a look at a couple of application
types and see how GCP lines up we'll
start simple with static websites no
fancy server stuff here just some raw
HTML and JavaScript files for
client-side processing for this example
Google Cloud Storage is the perfect
place to start
GCS offers global object storage and
fetching via URL so content can be
fetched directly without having to
invoke any server code uploads are
available almost immediately replicated
and backed up worldwide on Google's
Network and infrastructure with
partnerships with CDN
around the world pcs can also reduce the
cost of and speed to access your content
and the best part you can create a
domain that points right to your GCS
buckets so to users it looks like a
regular website they don't need to worry
themselves about the whole infinitely
scalable CDN thing so far so good but
also pretty simple next let's look at
something a little bit more complex but
still very common Virtual Private
servers
these are VMs running somewhere in the
cloud you might be running a game server
or a chat bot or anything else that
needs a dedicated machine and root
access Google compute engine can do the
same thing for you but comes with a lot
more bells and whistles GCE is a full
infrastructure as a service offering
including a set of Linux and window in
ajiz and the ability to configure your
VMs with the exact CPU and RAM
specifications that you need it's also
got a lot of other handy stuff that you
might not find elsewhere like out live
migration multiple regions support local
SSDs instant snapshots and preemptable
VMs not to mention production level
things like auto scaling health check
systems and
integration into stackdriver which
provides tracing error handling and
monitoring on your behalf so if you're
running a private server but don't want
to deal with all the overhead of
managing a private server GCE is a great
option but in reality there's a good
chance that you have an application
which is a mix of the two you serve some
static content but also have server-side
compute needs in that case doing all the
heavy lifting of managing dedicated VMs
and paying for them might be overkill
which is exactly what the platform as a
service offerings are for app engine
standard lets you serve static content
and also provides a server-side compute
interact with we handle all the
deployment migration regions and scaling
and you get to focus on getting your app
to users GAE standard has a flexible
billing model and allows your app to
scale down to zero instances so you
don't pay if no one's using it plus it
has built-in access to other GCP
services like datastore cloud sequel
memcache bigquery auth and more the
trade-off for all these benefits is that
App Engine standard comes with a few
restrictions there's a fixed set of
supported languages and you don't get
access to the disk of the instance and
you definitely don't have root access
but if you're just deploying a client
service system with minimal headache
that's an easy trade-off to make if you
do need more control but still want all
the managed goodness App Engine flex is
worth investigating flex gives you all
the same management auto scaling and
bandwidth splitting as standard but also
lets you run with full route privileges
with any language or container you want
the trade-off here is that flex doesn't
allow you to scale to zero and has a
different pricing structure so you'll
definitely want to make sure to check
out the pricing calculator finally let's
talk about hybrid clouds if you're a
company with a lot of on-premise servers
chances are you're not too keen to buy
new racks every month to handle spikes
in workloads instead GCP offers a
reliable VPN service that allows
on-demand GCP instances to connect
securely to your on-premise systems that
means that you can seamlessly spin up
new instances in Google's cloud to
handle workload spikes and spin them
down when they are needed which is way
better than buying them yourself and
having them sit
around idle when they're not being used
so if you want more recaps on great next
content make sure to check out the rest
of our playlist and don't forget the
next world tour coming soon to a city
near you
[Music]